der weg hat heute nacht so geklingelt
ich bin dementsprechend aufgestanden ins
bad gegangen bei eine typische
morgendliche 50 minuten takt session
geschoben und bin doch snapshot gegangen
war ich mal sehen wollte wer von meinen
ganzen zahlreichen freunden die ich dort
habe mir sonst nap geschickt hat niemand
außer dem snap chat natürlich mal wieder
haben und einzig mit den flammen herr
papa egal ich will auf jeden fall so ein
bisschen in die stories gegangen rechts
bei snap chat so basso hochgeladen wurde
und dann auf einmal sehe ich in meinem
profil so eine komische anzeige die ich
gesehen hab ne plus exklusive
experimentelle und noch nicht
veröffentlicht der features ich hab das
dann einfach so zur kenntnis genommen
mich wieder ins bett gelegt
denkste
uwe kling auswählen und dann ist mir ist
aufgefallen dass das ja wieder so ein
scheiß abo modell ist nicht dass dies
schon auf das sich jeden monat 1290
nichts ausgeben da habe ich aber zum
teil
bloß dann habe ich gesagt hast mich doch
einfach einmal gern 500 euro zahlen und
dann habe ich das leben lang und ich
denke wenn ich jeden monat aufs neue
wenn ich täglich wir haben das abgewogen
aber gut ich hab dann auf jeden fall
realisiert dass es drei verschiedene abo
modelle gibt und zwar einmal dass ein
monats modell bis vier euro 9 14 monate
an das sechs monats modell für 24 euro
49 in sechs monaten und das zwölfmonats
modell von 44 eur 99 im jahr zahlt
dementsprechend wie lang man sich
verpflichtet das zu haben spart man
dementsprechend natürlich auch rabatz
und ganz unten stand damit kostenlose
sieben tage testversion starte ich hab
natürlich gibt
du hast endlos erfolgreich abonniert ich
hoffe dass ihr auch mein youtube-kanal
erfolgreich abonniert hat
ist im gegensatz zu selbst ad plus
allerdings komplett kostenlos für euch
also mach das mal gerne zurück zum
eigentlichen thema ich habe das wie
gesagt heute morgen entdeckt als sie auf
dem podcast schwimm eine wurster ins
weiße haus gesetzt habe und habe mir
wirklich maler ersten moment gedacht
selbst plus wäre jetzt für mich
irgendwie was ich habe ja so quasi
seinen blauen haag auf snap der seiten
sterben wenn man die defizite sowie auf
install der blaue hakt allerdings kann
sich das wirklich jeder holen
jeder
und das soll nicht arrogant jetzt von
mir klingen dass ich denke das haben nur
andere leute verdient oder was weiß ich
was aber jeder
wirklich jeder
user kann sich das kaufen und ihr vater
auch gleich warum ich das gerade so oft
wiederholt habe denn ich habe wieder
einmal die features von sap chat bloß
angeschaut also mitglied seit sechs der
juli 2022 also heute
weil ja ich heute morgen kaka und ist
dann halt gesehen hab ich noch erwähnen
dass ich packen aber die wurst war gut
die war so richtig fett aber so
dreigeteilt das ging recht gute muss
auch einmal ab das oberste feature was
wir bekommen ist auf jeden fall das
symbol des ist wirklich der komplette
bullshit also ich bin froh dass ich
gerade aktuell diese testversion habe
weil ich werde das auf jeden fall nach
diesem video hier direkt kündigen aber
aus recherchezwecken und
journalistischen gründen habe ich mir
natürlich nur für euch geholt nicht für
die sachen die ich euch gleich erwähnt
werde die höchst interessant sind oder
wir kommen erst mal zurück zum app
symbol da sind halt verschiedene symbole
dementsprechend dass man dann halt
anklickt so sieht die app dann halt auf
dem homescreen aus als es ist genauso
wie wenn man bei tolingo dieses premium
den kauf gut gehen aber weg von apps
symbol nächstes feature beste freunde
für immer habe ich dann auch drauf
geklickt und dann kommt nur das hier als
super besten freund markieren halte
einen freund gedrückt um ihnen halt
super besten freund zu markieren und das
ist halt einfach eine ganz dumme
funktion und zwar kannst du einfach auf
einen freund draufklicken auf sein
profil geben kann dann sagen das ist
jetzt mein super bester freund
das waren wir jedoch weiter mit dem
nächsten
atemberaubenden feature von cnet
ich zumindest champion nennen können es
hat mich direkt an bild plus und damit
also ziehe ich eigentlich nur scheiße
das nächste feature ist allerdings auf
jeden fall das snapshot plus patch dann
hat man quasi wie sonnen verifiziert
sternen auch sowas
und das ist halt dumm weil das wäre
genauso wie wenn du auf die nester sagt
hey wenn ihr monatlich sieben euro oder
90 zahlt kriegt ja auch in verifizierten
hakt aber das macht gar keinen sinn weil
es wird voll viele leute geben die sich
justin bieber auf snap chat nennen und
dann sich diese snapshot plus und dann
denken andere leute oh das ist wirklich
justin bieber dann schreibt es so kleine
zwölfjährige fans an irgendwie mit
seinem fake account und dann schicken
die die noch irgendwelche komischen
bilder und dahinter steckt ein
60-jähriger pädo oder so was ist das für
ein schwachsinn machen wer allerdings
weiter mit einem feature was sehr sehr
viele kontrollen leute da draußen oder
halt einfach aufstocker sehr sehr feiern
werden und zwar ist es einerseits die
anzahl der story wiederholungen dass man
jetzt sieht wie oft eine person sich
deine story angeguckt hat das ist
wirklich ein game changer das mit der
sichtbarkeit der anzahl der story
wiederholungen ist aber noch nicht die
spitze vom eisberg meiner lieben freunde
denn macht euch auf das gratis feature
von snapshot plus gefasst ihr könnt
jetzt
ein
laufen ist das heißt nämlich ghost
trails auf deutsch übersetzt heißt das
die wanderwege eines geistes ist ja
nirgends ein schlechter deutsche
horrorfilm auf wunsch bestellt und man
kann dann wirklich sehen ich lass euch
hier mal ein das ist von einer freundin
von mir aus hamburg ich bin endlich
wieder ihr gesichtern oder koffer
sondern einfach nur nicht dass kollege
hat so ein bisschen durch die app durch
da siehst du wirklich wo diese person
vorher war du siehst nicht ganz genau wo
sie lang gefahren ist weil das zu krass
wäre aber du siehst wo die personen dort
war dann wieder dort und dann dort das
heißt beweist anhand von slapshot nicht
nur wo sich eine person anhand der
stepmap aktuell befindet was doch bei wo
ist sie ist oder einen anderen apps für
den standort an einer person schicken
kann sondern du siehst auch nachträglich
wo die person vorher war
das
bringt stalking und kontrolle auf ein
komplett neues level auf der snapshot
website steht übrigens you can go
straight talk lingo spot on wenn auf in
ihrer sap map settings das heißt
beispielsweise fritz und michelle in der
beziehung fritz sagt michael gute nacht
schlafen fritz sagt dann ich gehe jetzt
mal zu der
hatte bisschen liebe wieder zurück und
dann erst verdammt michelle meine
freundin hat ja seit neuestem snapshot
plus die sieht wo ich war aber ich kann
einfach in ghost noch mal ausmachen
januar machen dann ist das pack wo er
den vier letzten vier stunden war
zu jeder zeit in der wir leben es ist
einfach wirklich black mirror in real
life mittlerweile und ich bin auch ganz
ehrlich freunde ich will dieses video
jetzt noch weiter aus dem rahmen
sprengen die sg schon passiert ist ich
wollte euch einfach nur snapshot plus
vorstellen die features zeigen und ich
hätte euch auch gern irgendwas gezeigt
was ich damit jetzt hätte machen können
aber ich mache keine stories of snap
chat ich mache dir auf instagram könnt
ihr mir gerne folge witzigen content auf
tik tok heißt auch laser luca könnte mir
auch gern voll was bringt das einzige
was ich euch hätte zeigen können habe
ich getan dass man leute verfolgen kann
allerdings habe ich sehr sehr wenig
leute ob sap wird und ich finde es wert
dass man diese location an hat in
amerika ist es gang und gäbe ich bleibe
euch welche bilder ein wie das dabei
fast allen aussieht selbst das generell
irgendwie tot in deutschland gerade in
amerika chatten die leute fast nur mit
snap chat aber gut freunde lange rede
kurzer sinn kauft euch kein snapshot
premium denn es ist wirklich scheiße
wenn man das sofort ich finde man sollte
wirklich streiken ich kann es jetzt
wirklich voll und ganz verstehen dass
sie ihren leuten das geben wollen was
die leute wollen und wenn sie dafür
natürlich auch geld nehmen können dann
machen sie das natürlich aber es ist
wirkliche lust wenn man sagt man zahlt
diese 5 euro monat um das zu machen klar
fünf euro ist nicht viel aber die zeit
ist einerseits jeden monat und die
sachen die du dort bekommst sind einfach
nur sachen die psychisch kranke leute
wissen wollen wo war die person vor mir
wie viele leute gucken sie das video wie
häufig an rhein und
main bis ich verlinke euch hier ein
unfassbar gutes video das habe ich
letztes im podcast mal erwähnt er geht
es darum dass man so ein fauxpas
minijobs beim achten sollte müsst ihr
nicht in der härte waren dies hier
verlinkt ist aber schaut euch gern mal
an ansonsten könnt ihr hier und meinen
kanal abonnieren und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder in einem neuen video
ich sage jetzt mal weiter meine freunde